[Music]
adam is with us in atlanta hi adam
welcome to the ramsay show
hi guys thank you for having me sure
what's up
so i'm uh i've made some pretty pretty
dumb mistakes and i'm uh i'm pretty
terrified of making some more so i was
hoping i could get some advice on uh
i guess how i can move forward with
getting a house
i've got some car debt from some pretty
stupid mistakes
been there done that trying to get rid
of it now
i've got about twenty thousand dollars
in savings um that i could either use to
dump into the car debt and try and get
rid of as fast as possible
or do i try and keep building off of
that to get enough for a down payment
for the house cool
good that's a good question it's a valid
question how old are you
i am 29 okay and you're fairly new to
this whole ramsey stuff right
um
i've been around it a lot but pretty
much ignored it most of my life but uh
that means you're new to it i'm trying
to
get started now that's okay that's okay
it's all good and um what do you make of
your
i'm right around 105 000 a year good for
you and you're single
i am okay what do you owe on the car
uh right around 38 000 okay is that your
only debt
um
i kicked my student loans to the curb
last month they are gone now way to go
yeah the car is it the car is it all
right well there's two ways to go at
this okay
the fast way to get a house
is dump the car
and get you cheap get you a cheap car
and pay cash for it
the slow way to get a house is get the
car paid off and then save up your down
payment
i tell people and
and there's a reason for this i don't
just it's not just because
i don't want people here's the thing i
want you on a house i grew up in the
real estate business i love real estate
i think owning real estate is an
essential part of building wealth long
term so i do want you to get a house i
just don't want the house to get you and
when you have a 38 thousand dollar car
debt you don't need a house till you get
that mess cleaned up okay because it's
gonna bite you in the butt
uh so i want you to have here's the
thing you move into a house with a car
debt and no money and you put all your
money down on the house as soon as you
do something's gonna break on the house
the roof's gonna leak
yep just murphy's law okay but if you
move into a house with no car debt and
an emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses and put your down payment
down and you got so you got money in the
bank no debt when you move in nothing
will happen to this house it'll be
perfect you'll love it
that's how life works man what kind of
car is it
uh it's a the late model key it's a
couple years old
what could you get for it right now
probably more than i paid for it
probably more than 38.
i could probably get around 45 according
to kelly blue look brother sell it
yesterday
do you love this car has it wormed its
way into your heart
um i do like it but i don't know if i
like it that much yeah so here's the
thing yeah i'd sell it what i just told
you was the best way the only way i
would tell you to buy a house and i do
want you to buy a house
is when you have no debt and have an
emergency fund plus your down payment
okay
got so the two ways to get there are
quickly dump the car buy a seven
thousand dollar car for cash you have no
debt build your emergency fund and build
your down payment then buy you a house
that's gonna happen very quick you'll
have a house by christmas
or
pay this car off
keep it
build your emergency fund
build your down payment and you'll have
a house by
the next christmas
or the one after that either one's okay
there's nothing dumb here because the
car is not completely out of control
given your income it's getting close but
it's not completely out of control the
if you want to know what out of control
is don't own things with wheels and
motors all totaled up to be equal more
than half your annual income
and you're not there fair enough unless
you got other things with wheels or
motors that we don't know about sir but
if this is the only one you got it's
below half your annual income so it's
keeper it's okay but you need to get it
paid off for you by a house or the stars
have aligned and you can get rid of this
thing you can have seven thousand bucks
you can walk over to the lot and buy a
beater
and seven thousand right
a sustainable car yeah and man now
you're talking you're debt-free you got
20 grand in the bank you were well on
your way now you can buy george
campbell's honda for less than seven
thousand you could buy that for about a
dollar forty-five have you seen that
thing
he starts it with a rope out in the
parking lot dude
it's ridiculous
a rope i tried to spin the propeller to
get it just i drive bad cars and that
car makes me go come on man
george is truly not a car guy i've been
giving him a hard time on the air about
his car so yeah you could go either way
adam uh personally i like cars i'm a car
guy
uh but i like houses more
because they go up in value
and until recently cars have never gone
up in value and they won't long term but
recently they have been
uh so i personally would dump the stupid
thing while the getting's good and get
me a house
and then move up in car with cash later
after i get my house
but it's not a big deal either way
you're not in the dumb column either
direction
i compared that with what you and i have
done before
you're nowhere near us adam yeah yeah
you you got us both of us beat i mean
and you're a lot smarter than we were